[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission à ne pas manquer si
vous êtes un amoureux du sport local
c'est parti pour le sommaire de ce
magazine volley ball le club de conflans
andresy jouy a réalisé une belle
opération ce week-end dans le
championnat élite en gagnant contre
charenton sur son terrain le score de 3
sets à 0 reportage à suivre
joe 2024 le président de paris 2024 tony
estanguet était ce mercredi au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
il est venu rencontrer des jeunes à
l'occasion de la semaine olympique les
détails dans cette émission
cyclisme sur piste nous recevrons dans
quelques instants l'ancien pistard de
l'équipe de france françois pervis le
sportif cette fois champion du monde qui
habite aujourd'hui le mesnil saint denis
va participer aux jeux paralympiques en
tandem avec un malvoyant interview à
suivre l'actualité sportive de la
semaine c'est maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence tout de suite par du volley
ball ce dimanche le club de conflans
andresy jouy recevait charenton pour le
compte de la 7e journée du championnat
élite et les yvelinois l'ont emporté
assez facilement en trois sets à zéro
les détails dans ce reportage
des images de célia gars tsongo à un
montage de xavier jaglin un match à
enjeu à conflans sainte honorine ce
dimanche 7 février le club local le caj
volley-ball recevait charenton dans le
championnat élite
les joueurs de michel hunault ont
largement dominé la partie dans le
premier set les bleus l'emportent 25 à
20 ils ne font pas de détails dans les
deux sets suivants 25 à 15 et 25 à 18
score final 3 sets à 0 je pense qu on
était peut-être un petit peu mieux
préparés puis ils ont joué ils ont joué
aussi
hier soir un match en retard vous savez
avec les problèmes de covile on essaye
de calais un peu les matches en retard
un peu comme on peut donc je pense
qu'ils étaient aussi très émoussé nous
entre guillemets c'était pas notre
problème il fallait qu'on fasse notre
match qu'on soit concentré sur ce qu'on
avait à faire et on l'a très bien fait
ce déplacement le club de conflans
andresy jouy romont dans le top 5 du
championnat élite à sept points du
podium
l'équipe affiche un bilan de quatre
matchs gagnés et 5 perdu un peu grâce à
cette victoire maintenant comme je
disais on va pouvoir vraiment regardé en
haut et arrêter de regarder en bas du
classement
donc pour nous c'est un peu une bouffée
d'air et c'est aussi porter
d'entre eux très bon espoir pour la
suite nos objectifs et jouer le haut de
tableau
voilà c'était ça en début de saison on
n'a pas très bien géré la situation
sanitaire et qui après comme je voulais
dit de perdre des matches ça fait qu' on
est un petit peu en difficulté on doute
donc il a fallu relancer les joueurs et
donc on essaie d'être dans les trois
quatre premiers ce qui est un petit peu
plus conforme à nos à notre volonté
pourraient bien prochain match pour le
caj vbci samedi 13 février à 19h les
yvelinois se déplaceront sur le terrain
deux armes pour le compte de la 14e
journée du championnat et un mot de la
coupe de france de football ce lundi on
aurait dû vous parler du match de
conflans contre saint brice pour le
compte du 7e tour de la compétition
mais les conflits n'ont pas pu jouer ce
match-là raison ils ont perdu sur tapis
vert contre vitry malgré leur victoire 2
à 0 dimanche dernier les joueurs de carl
priso ont aligné un joueur suspendu lors
de cette rencontre ce qui est évidemment
interdit l'annoncé tombée dans la
semaine on écoute la réaction de
l'entraîneur carl priso la tristesse la
colère
en ce qui me concerne moi c'est la
tristesse si vous voulez j'ai une
contagion émotionnelle de mes joueurs
c'est à dire qu'une vingtaine de joueurs
qui sont pas bien leurs émotions et puis
plus aliens ajouté puis celle des
supporters du club
ça c'est difficile le club est meurtri
et c'est peu dire pour la petite
histoire vitré a perdu son match 4 buts
à 0 à domicile contre saint brice et
sort donc de cette coupe de france
on prend maintenant la direction du
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines ce mercredi tony estanguet
le président du comité d'organisation
des jeux olympiques et paralympiques
2024 est venu à la rencontre des jeunes
dans le cadre de la semaine olympique
des images de bixente mérian santisteva
l'ancien champion de canoë tony
estanguet s'est mis au cyclisme le temps
d'un après midi le président du comité
d'organisation de paris 2024 était ce
mercredi 3 février au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
son objectif promouvoir le site retenu
pour les jo-2010 le cadre de la semaine
olympique
on est ravi de pouvoir partager ce
moment avec la génération 2020
c'est tellement important au delà des
compétitions d'engager d'entraîner avec
nous cette génération de leur donner
envie de découvrir ces sports leur
donner envie de découvrir aussi des
athlètes et voilà moi je remercie toutes
celles et ceux qui ont permis cette
opération cette semaine olympique et
paralympique à l'école parce que cette
semaine on va mobiliser 500 mille
enfants qui un peu partout sur le
territoire vont être mieux sensibilisés
à l'importance de la pratique sportive
cette semaine olympique a été lancé à
l'initiative de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse et des sports
cet après midi une centaine de lycéens
de saint quentin en yvelines a pu tester
le vtt et le bmx avec le triple médaillé
d'or aux jo ça fait plaisir de voir sur
quoi les futurs athlètes ils vont
travailler et c'est franchement ça fait
plaisir de voir un athlète de niveau
ça m'a donné envie de voir les jo mais
voir le bmx géo il faut quand même
heureux si tu es ça dans un contexte
historique que les jeux en france et une
fois tous les cent ans
si on regarde derrière nous et que l'on
puisse associer le plus possible la
jeunesse à l'engouement que ça va
provoquer autour du sport c'est à mon
avis ce qu'il faut absolument pas
manquer dans la proche du de ces jeux
olympiques de 2024 la semaine olympique
s'est terminé ce vendredi sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
avec la découverte de la colline
d'elancourt le site recevra les épreuves
de vtt en 2024
le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines a également participé à cette
semaine olympique et paralympique ce
mardi 2 février les enfants étaient
reçus pour découvrir le golf au
programme des activités ludiques et la
découverte du site
un reportage de bixente mérian
santisteban dans le cadre de la semaine
olympique et paralympique le creps ile
de france organisée cette semaine des
activités pour les classes de primaire
ce mardi 2 février c'était découverte du
golf au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines première
activité qu'on a fait et vous devez tir
détourné avec les balles ces voix là est
la deuxième on apprend
des petits secrets pour tirer dans le
trou que c'est la première fois que j'ai
dû douala et même si j'arrive pas ça
très bien
bon là j'ai compris comment
en plus des différents jeux ludiques une
visite du 18 trous qui a accueilli la
ryder cup 2018 et sites olympiques de
paris 2024 les jeunes sur les lieux le
fort de demain on a maintenant voilà les
champs jusqu'aux jeux olympiques pour
pour préparer pour les sensibiliser pour
leur montrer que voilà sur la sur la
commune de saint quentin en yvelines
avait voilà il ya magnifique outil sur
lequel ils pourront j'espère un jour
voir demain pratiquer le golf donc
c'était très bien en vue de les
accueillir comme parrain de cette
semaine olympique et paralympique le
jeune à carreaux avaler 16 ans connu
pour son combat pour l'insertion
professionnelle des diabétiques
il intervient auprès des jeunes pour les
sensibiliser sur la thématique du sport
santé à chaque classe j'essaie de les
sensibiliser par rapport à cette maladie
donc moi même je suis diabétique de type
1 depuis quatre ans maintenant et donc
je les sensibilise par rapport à cette
maladie à la gestion cette maladie au
niveau du sport et aux bienfaits du
sport pour les personnes diabétiques
mais aussi non diabétiques parce que ça
permet on devrait virer équilibre au
niveau du fonctionnement du corps au
total ce sont plusieurs centaines
d'élèves répartis tout au long de la
semaine pour cette découverte sur le
green du golf national
on continue à parler des jeux olympiques
et paralympiques mais cette fois-ci de
2021 ceux de tokyo françois pervis sept
fois champion du monde sur piste s'est
lancé un nouveau défi le sportif du à
mesnil saint denis veut participer aux
jeux paralympiques au japon il
participera des épreuves sur piste en
tandem avec raphaël baud juillet un
malvoyant pour nous parler de ce projet
nous recevons sur ce plateau françois
pervis bonsoir bonsoir
alors pourquoi vous êtes lancés dans
cette aventure françois tout simplement
parce que j'avais besoin de nouveaux
défis
et puis c'est un défi aussi qu'on est
venu me proposer
donc après une petite réflexion j'ai
tout accepté parce que c'est
c'est vraiment un beau défi
d'accompagner un malvoyant pour aller
tenter de décrocher une médaille
paralympique aux jeux de tokyo
vous étiez imaginer peut-être faire ça
dans votre carrière ou pas du tout
absolument pas absolument pas
on est dans le filet valide on va dire
on est vraiment focus sur nos yeux sur
nos objectifs et non je me suis jamais
douté que j'allais faire ça pour finir
ma carrière
alors comment ça s'est passé c'est
raphaël bojic est venue vers vous et où
celle inverse ça s'est passé comment
fait expliqué nous l'a fait d'ailleurs
d'être alors à la base c'est la fsc la
fédération française de cyclisme qui a
annoncé très tôt qui ne comptait qu elle
ne comptait plus sur moi pour les jeux
valide de tokyo donc tout de suite la
fédération française de handisport est
venu me contacter et puis est venu me
présenter le projet et c'est pour
répondre à la question c'est la ffh
fédération française de handisport qui
est venu contacter qui m'a proposé ce
projet là et vous avez signé tout de
suite
tassé montre tout de suite et ses jeux
au japon c'est d'autant plus peut être
important pour vous vouliez absolument y
participer on sait que vous adorez ce
pays notamment vous y alliez pendant de
nombreux mois des fois pour vous
entraîner
oui j'y suis allé pendant six ans tous
les ans pendant 6 ans 4 à 5 mois tous
les ans je prend actuellement des cours
de japonais ma fille non un nom japonais
donc je suis je suis très très japonais
à la serre une passion pour moi la bosse
j'ai découvert une culture un pays
vraiment incroyable
j'ai été marqué aussi j'ai vécu l'avant
fukushima après fukushima
j'ai vraiment été marqué par ce pays là
il m'a vraiment aidé à me recentrer sur
moi et à prendre confiance en moi et
donc avant d'y aller j'étais jamais
champion du monde et en allant là bas
tous les ans quand je revenais de mon
stage là-bas ça m'aidait à devenir
champion du monde
donc c'est vraiment un pays qui compte
énormément pour moi et si je pouvais
finir ma carrière sur le médaille
paralympique
là-bas ce serait tout simplement la plus
belle des fins guerrières que je puisse
espérer alors justement pour avoir cette
médaille olympique comment ça se passe
expliquez-nous
est ce que vous vous entraînez tous les
jours régulièrement expliqué nous alors
on sent moins personnellement déjà comme
mon binôme raphaël on s'entraîne deux
fois par jour six jours sur sept
chacun des deux côtés et par exemple le
tous les vendredis samedis on se rejoint
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et là on fait
des entraînements en commun tous les
deux pour améliorer notre coordination
et pour pouvoir s'habituer à forcer
ensemble parce que c'est beaucoup de
coordination ça s'acquiert pas aussi
facilement que ça donc on se voit deux
fois par semaine sur tout le week-end et
ont ensuite on part en stage on commence
à faire pas mal de stages donc là on se
voit tous les jours deux fois par jour
pendant une semaine et donc c'est ça
nous fait du bien à notre progression et
les chronos tombent et ça c'est vraiment
bon justement c'est le lieu idéal pour
progresser peut-être oui bleus depuis 50
ans nous nous devrons mas saint quentin
pour nous c'est notre bijou quand on l'a
attendu pendant des décennies donc
maintenant on a vraiment plus beaux
vélodrome de france on a vraiment
beaucoup de chance de l'avoir
et c'est vraiment un très bel outil qui
nous aident à bien s'entraîner dans des
très bonnes conditions d'entraînement
pour pouvoir aller chercher des
médailles pour la france aux
championnats du monde et aux jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
alors vous entraîner avec raphaël du
coup depuis début des années 2020 c'est
bien ça oui on sait ville avait combien
c'était prévu
que vous participez aux jeux
paralympiques de tokyo en 2020 on est
d'accord
au début quand tout ça a été validée que
j'ai annoncée avec la ffh notre notre
défi c'était en février 2020 donc à
l'époque les jeux n'étaient pas
repousser encore et on allait rentrer
dans notre premier confinement donc ça
nous a pas empêchés de nous entraîner
très fort parce qu'on a eu du matériel
domicile pour pouvoir continuer à
s'entraîner deux fois par deux fois par
jour donc rafael a très bien progressé
de son côté et on s'est retrouvé à la
fin du confinement pour commencer à
travailler de notre coordination et
maintenant on est la coordination de
façon là travaillent à chaque
entraînement
mais maintenant on travaille vraiment
sur le physique tous les deux ensemble
et on progresse très bien et c'est c'est
super excitant et ça vous a aidé
justement ce déplacement des jo de 2020
à 2021 à cause du comité 19 ça nous a
énormément aidés et ça nous aide encore
puisque à l'époque il ya un an tout à
peine
on avait six mois devant nous six mois
devant nous mon coéquipier
c'est quelqu'un qui vient de la route
donc c'était avant tout un coureur
endurant et il fallait le transformer le
switch est en mode sprinteurs plus
d'explosivité sept joueurs se voient là
il faut beaucoup de force beaucoup
d'explosivité beaucoup de résistance
politique est de la puissance et donc
quand on est routier de base ça on en a
pas trop mais il a des très bonnes
qualités et donc depuis un an maintenant
il ne fait que du sprint que de la
musculation il a il a appris à
s'entraîner en musculation
maintenant il fait la musculation tous
les deux jours il fait des sprints de
tous les jours donc il a pris beaucoup
de force beaucoup de puissance et
d'explosivité et donc ils progressent
bien et c'est pour ça que nous à
l'époque on avait six mois maintenant on
a eu 18 mois après quand ils ont
repoussé d'un an
donc c'est pour ça que nous ce report là
c'est vraiment une aubaine pour nous
parce que progresse surtout rafael
progresse très très bien dans son de son
côté et qu'est-ce qui change finalement
sur sur le vélo vous étiez pas habitué à
ça courir avec quelqu'un forcément tout
le temps qu'est ce qui change finalement
il faut peut-être plus de communication
peut-être alors c'est compliqué de
parler justement alors effectivement
c'est un peu compliqué compliqué de
parler dans l'effort mais on se parle
surtout avant au moment de lancer le
sprint c'est à dire que déjà
dans les boxes au milieu de la piste
avant de monter en piste au détail de ce
prix on essaye de faire de l'imagerie
mentale
donc on visualise dans notre tête
comment on va là proche du sprint où est
ce qu'on va déclencher les sprints où
est ce qu'on va se mettre à 100 % on se
met debout on se rassoit
donc après ça une fois qu'on est sur le
vélo là on se parle aussi encore un
petit peu
toujours sur cette phase de lancement
pour lancer le sprint et par exemple
tout simplement je dis attention
hop j'ai averti qu'on va bientôt se
mettre debout et puis quand on sera soit
tout simplement je dis up et on se
rassoit
c'est vraiment pour pour être vraiment
bien coordonnée et raphaël m'a dit que à
terme on aura même plus besoin de se
parler parce qu'il va apprendre à
connaître dans mon ressenti à moi et il
va vraiment calquer son ses gestes par
rapport au mien et il m'a dit qu'à la
fin on a la même pile tous parlé ça va
être inné d'accord sur quoi vous devez
encore peut-être travailler pour avoir
cette médaille olympique
voilà on a encore beaucoup de travail
mais surtout sur le physique surtout sur
le physique alors moi à mon âge il faut
que je maintienne au niveau jeu pour
aller prendre six ans de ça j'ai 36 ans
et je vais avoir 37 ans afin de donner
donc pour un sprinteur c'est
relativement vieux
mon parcours raphaël il a encore une
très très bonne marge de progression
donc il faut vraiment qu'ils travaillent
très dur son physique et puis aussi son
mental parce que ça compte énormément
dans le cyclisme sur piste et aussi
enfin à quel âge
raphaël à 30 ans 30 ans 30 sujet la
question qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter tout simplement pour pour ces
prochains mois et cette échéance
olympique
alors pour ces prochains mois pas tout
finement pas de nouveaux cantonnements
mais on le souhaite aussi pour tout le
monde pour pour toute la population et
surtout pas de pépins physiques pas de
chute pas de voie là et puis tout
simplement continuer à évoluer comme ça
et pour les jeux tout simplement une
médaille d'or que je puisse finir ma
carrière avec raphaël sur médaille d'or
on vous le souhaite en tout cas merci
beaucoup françois pervis merci d'être
venu sur ce plateau on vous souhaite une
bonne préparation pour ces jeux
paralympiques et surtout un titre sur
ces jeux olympiques à tokyo la course
est programmée
normalement le 29 août à tokyo c'est
bien ça ne s'invente pas oui françois
pervis me ne serait pas le seul
yvelinois participent à ces jeux de
tokyo cette année mairie loket joueurs
de parra à badminton quintuple champion
de france et numéro cinq mondial devrait
également participer à ce rendez-vous
portrait de ce sportif originaire
d'andrésy par bixente mérian santisteva
c'était un entraînement plus en détente
que d'habitude pour merrill loket
le jeune balle liste de 23 ans a appris
récemment qu'il devrait participer aux
prochains jeux paralympiques à tokyo
c'est l'aboutissement de d'un
entraînement c'est à ces quatre ans de
préparation c'est du stress est long et
puis c'est le graal quoi c'est le graal
des compétitions et puis on représente
son pays à l'international c'est moi y'a
pas mieux plus jeunes le désormais
quintuple champion de france ne s'était
pas destiné au badminton
il a longtemps pratiqué le judo avec
pour idole un certain teddy riner qui me
disait là les sports de combat n'y a pas
plus dur comme entraînements et j'ai
découvert les entraînements de bad et je
suis sorti épuisé et la girouette est
pas ce que je veux moi je fais du sport
pour le support le surpassement
pour sa préparation merrill bénéficie du
soutien de la ville d'andrésy en plus de
la mise à disposition d'infrastructures
pour l'entraînement elle lui a accordé
une bonne
exceptionnel avec en plus le retard de
ces jeux d'une année on a vraiment donné
un gros coup de pouce pour sa
préparation pour pas qu'ils soient
démoralisé toute aide est bon à prendre
et quand s'avère d'une ville de là où on
a vécu toute notre vie ça fait encore
plus plaisir
objectif médaille à tokyo pour l'actuel
5e mondial et dans un petit coin de sa
tête plane le rêve de remporter les jeux
paralympiques de paris en 2024
on retourne au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines non pas pour parler
des jeux olympiques mais de l'open de
france 2021 les dates ont été
officiellement aux confirmés par le tour
européen la semaine dernière lors au
rendez vous sont organisés début mai sur
le golf saint quentinois les détails
dans ce reportage
un montage de lucas houdart la nouvelle
est tombée ce lundi 1er février le tour
européen et la fédération française de
golf ont annoncé la tenue de l'open de
france 2021
le rendez vous avait été annulé en 2020
suite à l'épidémie de covile 19 de la
joie alors tout simplement je pense que
c'est un c'est à une vraie très bonne
nouvelle on va dire de recevoir de
nouveaux devoirs sur le sur le
calendrier l'european tour
l'open de france à paraître c'est une
vraie bonne nouvelle à la fois pour les
licenciés à la fois pour les
collaborateurs du groupe national parce
que voilà ça va redonner à
un objectif commun de travail de
préparation pour cet événement qui est
un beau tournoi que top au tournoi qui
est vraiment apprécié adoré des joueurs
du tour cette 104e édition sera
organisée du 6 au 9 mai à saint quentin
en yvelines le rendez-vous connaît donc
un changement de date
le dernier open de france avait été
organisée en 2019 en octobre dans des
conditions automnales
cette fois ci les joueurs connaîtront
une météo printanière et data sont
bonnes un seul mois de mai à -2 mais bon
on est en région parisienne on sait que
ça peut être tout tous formidables ou a
peut-être un petit peu moins mais c'est
vrai que c'est une bonne date pour nous
un globalement ça arrivait un petit peu
tôt dans la saison mais on a un parcours
qui a bénéficié de voilà d'opérations de
préparation la ryder cup qui font que le
parcours sera après on fera tout pour
que le parcours soit prêt au mois de mai
oui les dates devraient également
attirer les meilleurs golfeurs français
le numéro un tricolore victor perez 34e
mondial a déjà annoncé c'est venu pour
nous l'open de france ceux déjà sur ont
réussi à avoir les meilleurs joueurs
français qui comme victor perez sont
parmi les joueurs mondiaux mais déjà
c'est réussi et c'est vrai que pour nous
avoir un plateau de joueurs français sur
l'open de france est une c'est une
excellente nouvelle une belle chose pour
nous seul inconnu désormais la présence
ou non du public sur cet événement à
l'heure actuelle aucun spectateur ne
devrait être présent en golf national
si l'open de france se jouera au mois de
mai il n'est pas certain de revoir du
sport en intérieur à cette date depuis
le début de la saison les clubs ont joué
très peu de matches et ne voient ils ne
voit pas encore le bout du tunnel pour
nous parler de ces sports en intérieur
nous recevons sur ce plateau à patrick
chabot ancien président du comité des
yvelines de handball est aujourd'hui
fondateur de l'association sport event
78 bonsoir bonsoir
alors nous avons également avec nous par
écran interposé à philippe femme le
président du club de basket de l'entente
le chesnay-versailles bonsoir bonsoir
alors comment analysez vous la situation
pour les sports à l'intérieur philippe
femme peut-être bon bah écoutez la
saison avait bien démarré puisqu'elle
avait démarré sur le même rythme que la
saison précédente alors qu'on ne
connaissait pas encore l'arrivée du coc
vide
et puis malheureusement mi-octobre tout
s'est arrêté c'est à dire que en ce qui
concerne les clubs qui étaient en
chantier de france comme le nôtre
nationale 2 féminine et nationale 3
masculine dont on a pu disputer trois
quatre matches et puis mi-octobre bon
malheureusement l'addition est arrivé
que le l'épidémie reprenait le dessus et
qu'il fallait stopper et depuis mi
octobre
hélas en ce qui concerne les seniors
donc les amateurs seniors
rien n'a pu se libérer donc ils sont
toujours bloqués au même niveau et puis
en ce qui concerne les jeunes on a pu
reprendre un petit peu à partir de
mi-décembre mais à nouveau nous sommes
totalement paralysé puisque hélas il a
été décidé de fermer tous les gymnases
c'est à dire toutes les salles indoor
compte tenu de la recrudescence de
l'épidémie ces derniers temps est-ce que
c'est dur pour les joueurs en ce moment
par derrière nous oui parce que on voit
que depuis beaucoup d'activités
notamment les sports collectifs qui sont
à l'arrêt depuis depuis la reprise de la
saison
effectivement puis en plus il ya des
conséquences derrière parce qu enfin
quand on a affaire à des professionnels
donc ils sont astreints s'entraîner
régulièrement pas forcément dans les
bonnes conditions
mais quand on aborde le sport amateur
même en championnat de france il faut
avoir le mental pour aller s'entraîner
et puis rester en forme
je vois l'équipe de handball de montigny
par exemple ils n'ont pas fait un seul
match de la saison donc et c'est général
à la région parisienne nous c'est vrai
pour le handball mais c'est vrai aussi
pour les autres sports
c'est fifa chez vous aussi c'est
compliqué les joueurs commencent à
tourner un peu en rond
ah oui c'est très compliqué c'est encore
plus compliqué pour les seniors que pour
les jeunes puisque les jeunes même si
aujourd'hui ils ont pu reprendre
on ne pouvait pas reprendre dans les
conditions normales puisque il était
interdit d'être je dirais en opposition
c'est à dire de pouvoir se toucher entre
guillemets donc c'était essentiellement
d'entraînement physique individuel même
si c'est en groupe par contre pour les
seniors depuis
octobre c'est c'est black out et on sait
très bien que un athlète amateur ne pas
s'entraîner comme un athlète
professionnel il a une activité où il se
forme et danser danser les conditions
malheureusement depuis maintenant trois
mois
toute activité a cessé sinon des
activités à titre individuel alors nous
on essaie bien au travers de la visio de
créer de l'émulation collective au
travers de d'entraînement qui permettent
effectivement de conserver un côté
collectif mais sur le plan à la fois du
sport collectif qui sur le plan de
l'effet de groupe bien entendu nous
avons perdu énormément
comment imaginez vous la suite de la
saison peut-être patrick chehab est ce
qu'on parle de saison blanche est ce que
ça sera le cas ou pas en tout cas on
balaie ce que vous avez des infos alors
d un faux-pas j'ai déjà vu lui que les
trois sports collectifs
donc basket hand et volley avait faire
un communiqué prochainement sur la
l'arrêt de la saison je sais pas où ça
en est fait mais visiblement ça ne peut
déboucher que là dessus sur une saison
blanche
c'est à dire bon là la saison sportive
quand on a fait zéro match bien on peut
pas se permettre
il est impossible de faire un calendrier
c'est trop tard les femmes est-ce qu'il
ya peut-être une deadline peut-être une
date limite pour pour reprendre les
matches tout simplement oui oui il ya
plusieurs scénarii qui ont été
travaillés justement de manière un peu
collectif par les fédérations à la fois
de basket de de handball d'agde et donc
de sport en intérieur il fallait toute
façon que toutes les fédérations et
défini un calendrier éventuellement figé
au 31 décembre
parce que c'est la règle c'est la loi
entre guillemets et dans ce cadre-là bon
plusieurs hypothèses ont été prises on
poursuit le championnat normalement on
le poursuit à moitié ou on ne poursuit
pas du tout et est déjà bon le le
championnat en totalité
c'est fini la pandémie qui se poursuit
fait que aujourd'hui effectivement il va
être de plus en plus difficile de
maintenir un championnat même je dirais
à mi chemin et comme l'a dit et patrick
chehab les ligues et les comités
départementaux de ces différents sports
intérieurs ont été sollicités et là en
ce moment et je parle du basket parce
que pour les autres sports je ne suis
pas au courant
les clubs fédéraux en champions de
france sont en train d'être je dirais à
questionner j'ai moi même répondu au nom
de mon club
par rapport au championnat de france
mais aussi au championnat en régions et
en départements et il est probable que
si nous ne pouvons pas reprendre très
rapidement et a priori ce ne sera pas le
cas on va vers je dirais l'arrêt des
championnats tels qu'ils étaient
programmés avec certainement
le fait de pouvoir déjà préparer la
saison suivante en mettant en place des
championnats alternatif mais sans enjeu
puisque évidemment là il ne sera pas
question ni de monter ni de descente ni
de titre
merci à tous les deux dépassé son
plateau désolé un patrick chan je sais
que vous vouliez à rajouter quelque
chose mais malheureusement le temps
l'émission ne nous le permet pas
merci à tous les deux en tout cas de
votre participation sédhiou donc déjà la
fin de cette émission so hausses on
retrouve bientôt pour un nouveau
magazine très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
oui